nos encontramos en el oeste de ucrania
aquí la situación es de parcial
normalidad no se han producido ataques
en las últimas horas y en la frontera
con polonia que hemos cruzado hoy hemos
visto largas colas de vehículos en
dirección de ucrania se trata de
personas que están regresando a este
país en ocasión de las fiestas de la
pascua ortodoxa muy diferente de la
situación en el este y sur de ucrania
donde los combates se han recrudecido en
las últimas semanas y también los
últimos días en el sur un alto mando
militar de rusia ha dicho que la
intención de moscú es avanzar hacia la
región separatista prorrusa de
transnistria en moldavia esto pondría en
la mira a odessa y a todo el sur de este
país se se trata de un cambio con
respecto a la situación que se conocía
anteriormente de las intenciones de
rusia de avanzar solo hacia la península
de crimea anexionada en el 2014 y todo
esto ocurre en una situación de
devastación de
ucrania de la guerra iniciada por
vladimir putin en este país se con a
decenas de miles de muertos en ciudades
como mariupol y también naciones unidas
que empiezan a hablar de indicios de
crímenes de guerra cometidos en este
país ejecuciones sumarias y bombardeos
indiscriminados contra la población
civil